broken windows patched up with cardboard
the workers inside large league shielded
from view this is Lester's textile
industry hundreds of factories in
crumbling buildings divided into a maze
of workshops where our cameras weren't
welcome the industry is being
investigated over allegations of
illegally low pay this MP says
exploitation is on a massive scale it's
around about 10,000 individuals who are
effectively in modern slavery providing
garments for internet retailers workers
are frightened this woman asked us not
to show her face
we've reavoice her words to protect her
identity how much do you get paid six
five five fifty per hour yeah a little
money little money and there are claims
some are earning even less machinist
I'll pay are being paid three cards an
hour Packers are being paid two pugs an
hour that is what this seems to be the
standard the industry is fueled by fast
fashion many factories in leicester
supply online retailers including boohoo
and its subsidiaries
boohoo has launched an independent
investigation into pay and conditions
the owner of this factory says he's been
visited by officials he checks my older
books and like they want to do the face
ba ye he says he's doing nothing wrong
and was happy for us to film with
workers in his factory
meaning long ways for everybody in the
streets around the factories immigration
officers have been patrolling amid
claims many workers are in the country
illegally a multi-agency investigation
is underway
many feel it's long overdue allegations
of exploitation in Lester's clothing
factories aren't new in fact it's been
an open secret in this city for years
everyone knows but nothing changes you
call it an open secret it's just open
you have a senior position in the City
Council do you feel ashamed but this is
still going on I think we should all
feel a sense of shame that exploitation
takes place anywhere you have to ask
yourself you know who actually has the
power to change this and book rests with
government the Home Office describes the
allegations as appalling and the
National Crime Agency is investigating
but Lester isn't the only city where
this is happening a report based on
police records has found Britain has at
least 100,000 slaves and one's
exploitation is happening right across
the country behind closed doors Becky
Johnson Sky News Lester